for today's classic interview we are
gonna dive into something that has
become very relevant who are the
participants in the battle of ideas does
the Overton Window tell us about a to
narrow score scope of political
identification and labels do left and
right still mean anything we've got
Trump and the alt right and corporate
Democrats and regressives and all this
other stuff so what are the meanings of
some of these political labels and do
they mean anything anymore well I was
joined by Crispin Sartre well back in
July of 2014 he argued that this
left-right political system is bogus and
it has arguably become even more bogus
in the context in the time of Trump and
all of this other stuff so let's get to
my interview with Crispin Sartre well
from July of 2014 and joy our guest
today is Crispin Sartre well who is an
associate professor of philosophy at
Dickinson College also author of a
number of books in political theory and
aesthetics today we're talking about an
article where Professor Sartre well says
that the left-right political spectrum
is bogus very interesting article I
think a good place to start as you know
many people may not know where this idea
of the left-right political spectrum as
a way to gauge political orientation
came from what why don't you tell us
about that first all right well I mean
one point in in this piece I wrote is
that there have been many ways of
thinking about arranging political
positions and how to think about the
range of political positions the
left-right spectrum which is so dominant
now as a way of conceiving political
positions really originates in the late
18th century during the French
Revolution where it referred to the
seating of monarchists and
anti-monarchists in the french assembly
the anti-monarchist being on the left
and the monarchist being on the right I
mean my feeling though is that for
example in the United States there was
no real left/right way of thinking about
politics until the early 20th century
and even in Europe I think it took a law
time to take cold after the French
Revolution and really only under under
Marxism or after Marxism became the
dominant way of conceiving the whole
range of political positions so I think
for our conversation it's important to
distinguish or to maybe
ascertain when you say that the
left-right political spectrum is bogus
do you mean that that way of determining
what someone's politics are is bogus or
do you actually mean that the positions
inherent to being left or right on the
spectrum aren't really left or right if
that question makes any sense it's not
really a coherent way of arranging
political positions and I also think
that basically any position on the left
or on the right that's clearly on the
left or the right
it's an internally coherent I mean I
guess my basic I mean there's different
ways of thinking about left and right
one might be sort of reactionary versus
progressive or in terms of time another
one might be state versus capital and
that's sort of the way this is played
out kind of I mean as I said the piece
I'm Rand versus Mao Zedong in a cage
match so thinking about it that way
though a state versus capital and you
know I think you have a mild version of
ein Rand versus mouth say to me in
American politics let's say well you
said in the article there was one line
that I think you just kind of alluded to
which is that it that that when you look
at anyone's position whether they
consider themselves liberal or
conservative that there will be internal
conflicts or that that position will be
internal and internally incoherent and I
thought that a good to explore this I
thought let's just take the issue of
abortion for example and just explore
how your analysis might apply there and
maybe maybe it will maybe it won't so
I'll give you my view on this right so
conservatives and liberals for the most
part both want to reduce the number of
abortions liberals believe the way to
reduce the number of abortions while
they should be Lee
goal is to teach reasonable sex
education not abstinence only and make
birth control available and make sure
people know how to use it
conservatives generally want to reduce
the number of abortions but they say the
way to do it is you teach abstinence
only sex education and you don't make
birth control easily accessible because
that'll encourage people to have sex now
okay those are two divergent views the
facts though when we look at studies
show that actually the liberal
prescription for reducing abortion works
whereas the conservative one doesn't so
tell us where are the incoherent parts
of either or both okay well I with
regard to abortion I think for example
if you look at conservatives you know
often they're defending individual
liberty and the right of a person to
control their own body in a pretty
fundamentalist way right right now that
is exactly the sort of defense of
abortion that you get on the Left
however I will say this about the left
they're enthusiastic as hell about all
kinds of restrictions on all kinds of
people by the state and if they're
defending abortion on the grounds that a
person has a more or less absolute right
to control their own body hmm then I
would like to see that principle
maintained consistently throughout a
series of leftist positions because what
I feel is that the left is basically
extremely enthusiastic about state power
as a solution to any given problem
except in a case for example like
abortion where they hop off and decide
that individual rights are important you
know that's fair and we have to say
though when we make that analysis the
exact inconsistency I would argue to a
greater degree exists on the right which
is well we don't want the government
getting involved except when all of a
sudden we want to prevent two men from
getting married all of a sudden were
hey with the government involved so so I
guess I'm seeing in this particular case
how you see that double standard on both
sides to some extent I agree I mean I
think the basic difference the way I
articulated is that the left is often
enthusiastic for state power the right
is often enthusiastic for corporate
power but those two kinds of power
cannot be pulled apart
they've coincided since the beginning of
capitalism and both the left and the
right are extremely enthusiastic about
their own form of hierarchy I think they
both really would like to tell you how
to live but hierarchies coincide this is
my principle the principle of
hierarchical coincidence so if you have
a economic hierarchy and a political
hierarchy they will tend to be the same
people and I'd say no claim has ever
been more richly empirically verified
than that so I think that you know I
left this prescription of very you know
heavyweight government activism say to
reduce income inequality is actually
liable to be counterproductive because
it manifests enthusiasm for political
hierarchy and political power increases
political power and political hierarchy
and that in the long run is just going
to freeze the economic hierarchy into
place which is exactly what's happened
so we have like a very aggressive
welfare state compared to what we have
had in the past for example or
compulsory education for example but all
but what the real effect of these as
these have taken place in equality
economic inequality has increased which
I say is actually a predictable result
because hierarchies tend to coincide so
if you increase political hierarchy you
tend to increase economic hierarchy and
so the less positions tend to be
counterproductive to their own
egalitarianism that's my view and and I
think if we were to do a full analysis
of that inequality issue we can't ignore
the push for deregulation the
disproportionate you know we hear from
the right about the reallocation
wealth accused to the left as a negative
thing but the stock market has actually
been one of the biggest redistributions
of wealth when we look at who owns stock
and economists are increasingly talking
about that so again I think there's
points to be made on both sides let me
present a different theory though and
I'm curious if you've read at all
George Lake Hoffs work where he
specifically talks about the strict
father point of view and the nurturing
father point of view and that one way to
tie together the apparent
inconsistencies that you and I have
pointed out in the left and the right is
no it's not so much about reducing
abortion period the reason why that
inconsistency exists well wait a second
why would you limit access to birth
control if it reduces abortions is the
right has a desire to impose strict
father morality which is no you can't
have sex and not have the consequences
if you have sex you need to have the
consequences and you need to birth that
child what do you think about that idea
this idea that that when we look at it
as state versus capital or the other
ways you spoke of another way is the
strict father morality versus the
nurturing father morality
among others is you don't need a daddy
you are a daddy okay if you're looking
if I was designing a daddy I would
design a friendly daddy you know
whatever maybe you need a strict daddy
I'm not sure but I would say like grow
the hell up okay you know and you know
nice daddy or mean daddy if you put your
life at his disposal then you're gonna
have to expect to get disposed of you
know so I mean I think it's time to grow
up man so what I'm trying to figure out
where does it's time to grow up fall
under the umbrella of personal
responsibility and the American
neoconservative right or what what is
it's time to grow up man
all under in this however we divide the
political spectrum well I mean probably
with libertarians like Rand Paul let's
say right yeah I'm getting that sense
from you yeah I'm an anarchist actually
though and I certainly wouldn't count
myself as being on the right okay yeah
but so I would think of political
positions in terms of whether they are
pro or anti hierarchical do they seek to
increase or to dismantle hierarchies of
power and wealth my problem with the
left and the right is that they seek to
increase hierarchies of power and wealth
you know they might not think so that
that's true of them but that's the
practical effect of both sorts of
policies so if you increase state
hierarchy you're going to increase up
the hierarchy of wealth if you increase
the hierarchy of wealth you're going to
increase state power and and so I would
try to reconsider our anti hierarchical
alright well that's certainly a
libertarian way to look at it you you're
absolutely right there so we've been
speaking with Professor Crispin start
well I want to have you back in the
future to talk about a very specific
question I have for libertarians which
is in a libertarian utopia who controls
the nuclear weapons but don't answer now
we'll have you back on and we will talk
about that thanks so much for being on
with us all right thanks so much